oui j'ai tardé pons de canon mais qui
n'est pas obligé de tout en fait voilà
merci mais que c'est ouf
ces genres commenté vidéo quoi une piéce
youtube bah non c'est pas ma psp tube
c'est ma chambre fins de l'offre c'est
comme en vidéo puisque c'est l'app store
day by day mais si tu veux pas genre
lagarde josette à claude van damme
aurait été trop sympa ensemble je
m'installe à comme ça chapeau à ta
question va et et voilà merci vous savez
ça défonce même d'être là alors guilhem
en ring et enfin guillaume guillem dire
parce que non il m'envoie une question
qui était est-ce que c'est mal d'être
superficiel vrai alors la superficialité
en gros c'est ce qui est limité à la
surface c'est ce qui n'est qu'apparent
ans ça se dit des gens qui s'intéressent
pas aux réalités profondes et du coup on
dit lorsqu'on est quelqu'un qui est
superficiel c'est assez péjoratif toi
c'est genre on va dire qu'il a une
absence de pignons un manque de culture
limite un déficit intellectuel enfin
bref c'est un truc vraiment pas cool
par exemple des gens qu'on pourrait
considérer comme a priori superficielle
seller youtube us beauté et les youtuber
beauté de quoi les youtube bar d'hôtel
du coup la superficialité c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est vue comme négative
par exemple quand hugues herbert nous
dit je porte toujours le même t-shirt
pour le même modèle la même couleur
c'est une manière de vous dire voilà je
perds pas mon temps dans la décision
superficielles moi au moins je
m'investis dans des choses profondes
j'investis longtemps dans ce à quoi
enfin zuckerberg c'était vraiment le
génie dont tout le monde parle
il n'aurait pas pris un gris qui est
plus à la mode depuis mai 2014 du tout
non ce n'est pas vraiment ce biais là
c'était un autre fin c'était pas tu veux
je te file un tee shirt
non je ne suis pas superficiel moi je
pense qu'il faut distinguer deux types
de superficialité
déjà il ya le superficiel des youtuber
beauté ou lifestyle donc je fais une
excellente cette version tâche est
d'ailleurs prêt à temps c'est quoi ça
tient mon jeu parce que ça c'est pas ça
tu as donc se trouvait-il de superbes c
était pour moi c'est une question de
goût et de passion quoique même façon
qu'on puisse être passionné je parle de
chevaux automobile ou neuf îlots et
bancs peut aussi l'être de make-up mode
ce genre de choses mais pas des passions
qu'ils soient mieux que d'autres
enfin la fille aux carrefours innovation
pourquoi on ne nous dit pas ça pour toi
moi je sais que tu t'en fous de la philo
de saprissa parce qu'il restait plus à
ce trio sud mais enfin sais pas quoi
enfin annonce par internet les 28
enfants et la superficialité bas si on
essaie de creuser on se rend compte
qu'en fait c'est passion qui serait
pourri c'est des passions qui sont
peut-être pas profonde qui portent pas
de vrais combats ou des idées nobles et
malin on arrive au second type de
superficialité celui qui ne touchent pas
juste à une affaire de goût mais qui est
plus global celui qui est lié à la
profondeur des choses
par exemple je vais être passionné de
philo mais la traiter superficiellement
et en vrai pourquoi la spécialité ce
sera un mal
bah ouais c'est justement le sens de ma
question oui je sais que j'y réponds l'a
annoncé c'est mon second prime
moi ce qui me déplaît lorsqu'on dit que
le profond et plus intéressant c'est que
mal quelque part on dénigre la
superficialité on dénigre l'apparence on
se moque d'elle alors que bâle apparence
le superficiel ça une valeur par
elle-même lorsque je vous parle des
océans on parle du fond des abysses mais
aussi de la surface c'est un peu comme
avec la peau par exemple qu'on veut la
traiter pour la traiter en profondeur
avec l'alimentation mais aussi avec une
superficialité avec bats qui met cap
exactement est tout à fait d'ailleurs en
parlant de make up je voulais vraiment à
4 non non c'est parce que moi je suis
vraiment
très make up donc si tu lance maintenant
je vais pas m'arrêter un c'est à cause
de ça non c'est un ensemble
celui qui a un problème avec cette
superficialité avec cette apparence et
qui cherche à tout prix quelque chose de
profond c'est celui qui a forcément
besoin de se raccrocher à quelque chose
parce qu'il a peur de faire emporter par
par les cubes quoi par les frivolités
c'est quelque chose qui me vient de
nietzsche qui pensaient que le fait
d'être superficiel c'était pour les
esprits libres qui n'ont pas besoin de
se rassurer en pensant que derrière des
apparences il ya des vérités plus
importante ah oui c'est
du coup c'est bien d'être superficiel
ouais ouais ben regarde de seconde les
grecs par exemple si on pense aux grecs
qui passaient leur temps à admirer les
belles choses et même à l'associer au
bien ce qu'on appelle khalid skah gâteau
ce que vous avez dit dans le premier
ascq et bien on ne peut pas dire que les
grecs étaient quand même nom profond
ouais c'est pour ça que nietzsche dit
qu'ils sont superficielles par
profondeur mais carrément tu communiques
un non pas du tout j'étais sur evene en
fait j'ai tapé superficialité c'est le
premier truc est sorti en plus de ça le
superficiel fait forcément écho à des
choses qui sont profondes ah bah oui
regarde par exemple nous les youtube
beauté basse a parlé superficiel mais il
ya des vraies valeurs d'entraidé partage
exactement et ça c'est du côté mec est
acteur de spécialités l'on peut aussi
être spectateur sait qu'on peut
s'indigner profondément de quelque chose
qui n'est qu'apparence par exemple pour
plus profondément s'indigner du dernier
vernis de je ne sais qui je n'en parle
pas c'est très bien de qui tu parles
ces tests et nous l'un d'eux se mariant
avec les chiens n'a pas résidents par
les sociétés genre en fait à partir du
moment où la superficialité un vrai
impact est ce qu'il faut la dénigrer bah
moi je pense que l'heureuse c'était une
question rhétorique la réponse est non
faut que tu le dis pas directement
non non il faut pas là des lieux après
les apparences sont parfois trompeuses
c'est vrai mais on peut pas contourner
les apparences si on peut comprendre les
choses globalement donc si je devais
résumer je dirais que non c'est pas un
mal d'être superficiel la superficialité
n'est pas à dénigrer par rapport à la
profondeur soit une question de moby ou
une volonté globale de ne pas
s'engouffrer dans les choses pour
pouvoir goûter un peu tout pas à l'homme
que tu dis qu'en fait ce qui est mal
c'est d'être en expert afin d'être un
geek manon pourquoi ce sera un mal
et je pense que pour conclure on peut
dire comme nietzsche que quiconque et à
sonder le fond des choses
devine sans peine quelle sagesse il ya à
rester superficielles c'était pas mal
mais j'ai bien dit ouais tu l'avant même
si j'ai appris que c'est pas con parce
que ça voulait dire monsieur mais de le
dire à quel paquet c'est ça rentre
parfaitement dans ma ce conseiller
mais du coup ça t'as plus ah ouais ouais
carrément s'arrêter tour ouais ouais 40
fois et je pense que je regardais à la
vidéo pour la fin je verrai bas parce
que ça fait vraiment plaisir du coup de
fer 7 collab est tous avec toi
ouais parce que j'adore tes vidéos je
t'avoue il ya un truc mec qui quand je
regarde les vidéos de youtube eux ce
serait marrant faire un tag mais tu vas
genre sur ma chaîne ça a pas de ça pas
trop de sens quoi en faire tu vas faire
un sur ma chaîne vas-y moi je veux pas
de souci bah ouais car on bat andy rihs
la caméra et on peut enfin m'a carrément
bas où c'est quoi sinon cliquez ici et
comme ça vous pouvez voir tout de suite
le times qu'on fait sur la chaîne de
gueule masculin singulier parce que j'ai
passé 12 a plus ces cas n'hésitez pas ta
en retour dans les commentaires et à me
dire ce que vous en avez pensé
merci à guillaume ii masculin singulier
quelle chaîne que j'apprécie et beaucoup
air donc c'est un plaisir de taper avec
lui sur ce sujet là on se retrouve
bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo vous
entendu l'homme et ex